You're saying that in the DG do server
they went after Pisco?
>> They do Pisco. Yeah. And the guy who who
>> Did that come from DG?
>> Uh yes. My saying uh you know we we
shouldn't we shouldn't think we
shouldn't think that he actually had
this on his computer to uh well he
hasn't been charged with anything that
we're aware of so we should just trust
him. Like I said
>> well I'm I'm operating from the
assumption that Destiny isn't a complete
idiot.
>> Yeah. See this is the thing is like you
have to sit here if you're a good
person, right? You have to sit here. Oh
dooby's not. And maybe I'm not for even
watching this once I knew what it was,
but it seems so it seems like such that
I had to sit here and pretend that I
don't know that this happened and that
somebody aligned with Destiny is not
responsible for it, right? And then I
had to listen to these talk to and
probably tell somebody around Pisco that
it's like, oh, it's like it's it's like
Jer Queen's fault that this happened.
It's like, bro, that the guy who did
this doxed a bunch of people who are
like anti- Destiny. The person, again,
I'll say the person who actually
originated Hutch's docs is somebody who
was in Dan's server discussing doxing
Hassan Piker's dad.
[Music]
People have really made, I don't know,
substantial statements on this whole
thing. The part where Lost and joined.
Wait, Lost joined? No way. I just I saw
that guy talking about this stuff. I
would love to uh I would totally talk to
that guy if he wanted to come on. Give
me a give me a time stamp. We got a time
stamp for that. Prime Kai. Prime Primai.
Prime Kai. See here. We got Prime Kai.
Loss is Oh, hold on. Is this Lost and
Harrison though? Okay, let's go. This
guy's getting aggressive.
>> That the account that posted Pisco's doc
is Dan on an alt account and that he was
involved not just
>> Oh, why is Doobie talking about this
>> that guy doxing of other people,
>> right?
server.
>> Oh. Uhoh. Wait, wait, wait. This is uh
>> difference between the typical
15-year-old and 19.
>> And the reason and the reason that there
is such a
>> that was some uh crazy [__] that just
got said and now listen, now you have my
now you have my attention. Okay, now
this panel suddenly has my attention.
Okay, like no, I can I can correct some
of the the talk around here. Okay, we'll
we'll go. We listen that came through.
We'll have to talk about it now. All
right. So, I'll I'll talk about it a
little bit. We'll hit play.
>> Is that
I dragged it back about 5 10 minutes.
Okay. I'm going to go get a little more
food and we're going to watch this.
>> Is has has not been in the body or mind
of a like they're still developing
number one. But even still, they're like
you can't look at it as 15 years of
experience versus 19 years of
experience. You have to look at it as a
15-year-old hasn't had um the hasn't
embodied a body that is predominantly or
mostly developed for like more than like
6 months at best, if they're even at
that stage, what they usually aren't.
And they haven't had any adult-like
experiences at all. Whereas a
19-year-old has been out in the world
having adult-like experiences. They've
they're they're going and renting
things. Maybe they're in college. Maybe
they've been to bars.
If they're doing the 1915 quote, like
unironically, like actually
unironically, they're going to do the
1915 quote. Are we serious right now?
Are we real? Is this real? Hello.
>> The difference in development and
experience between a 15-year-old and
19-year-old is vastly different than a
19-year-old and a 23-year-old. And the
reason behind this is because the
15-year-old has essentially no
experiences and the 19-year-old has
minimal experiences. So, um I want to uh
I'll let in because we still wanted to
uh say stuff, but
>> Okay, hold on before we get into this.
We got a Mantis tweet. We got a Mantis
tweet that actually kind of goes crazy
because she doesn't understand that we
all knew this. So, before I pull it up
even, I'm going to say she doesn't
understand we all knew this. Let's check
it out. It is um how mad will the haters
be when this drama blows over and people
still prefer Destiny to them? Not even
CP can do it. smells like victory.
No, we literally all thought this about
you already. We all knew that you guys
wouldn't care what Destiny did no matter
what. We all knew that child wouldn't be
the line. We all knew that you'd be
totally cool with this guy being a like
literally everybody. You you literally
just said something. You're like, "Huh,
they they think that we'd leave even if
he's a Nope. None of us think that. We
all know you're disgusting freaks. We've
all thought you were disgusting freaks
for a long time.
You're not shocking me with this
statement. We all know you're a
disgusting freak. We all know you you
revel in being disgusting freaks.
You You've just said something that
totally confirms everything I already
thought. Thank you. Nothing's changed.
Goodbye. This is This is a crazy thing
to tweet like, "Huh? They thought child
would make me go away." Nope. No. None
of us thought that. Crazy. Crazy to just
like self- emilate like that on Twitter.
>> Just quickly, uh
>> I just got here. Before I go back, did
we cover uh Destiny crashing out over
Ethan today? No, we haven't covered that
at all, but uh we will be covering it
eventually, Matt. Yeah, we'll be
covering it eventually. I actually,
frankly, totally forgot about it, but
we're gonna watch this guy, this caller,
real quick, and then we'll uh I think
we'll get to that.
>> Um chat from uh Mcdevin $2 says Taylor
Swift dated Shark Boy uh when he was 17.
Okay,
>> good for him.
>> She was 19 Chad.
>> She was 19. She was I don't give a about
that.
>> Yeah. Um and uh and I'll say just one
thing quickly on what uh Scott said. I
think adult situation
>> Lawson please like
>> Mhm.
>> if we want to say well look you know
there not you know both 15year-olds and
19 year olds like they're really just
kids when you think about it right both
of them they're pretty dumb. They're you
know you know airheads.
>> Yeah we have lines.
>> Are you serious? We we got to draw a
line somewhere, right? Because I also I
sure which we have, right?
>> Jesus.
>> But like
so so
do you think there's Okay, there's a
legal obviously a legal difference at
18. Do you think there's like a moral
difference?
>> Um
between 15 and and 19.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, probably.
>> All right. Well, there you go.
>> It's not a black and white. Like I I
don't we don't need to have the age of
consent conversation, but like no one no
one here is going to say with a serious
straight face that like
>> the 17
>> Come on, guys. You're not going to have
the age of consent. Conor made a whole
chart. Conor made an entire chart and
they're not even going to they're not
even going to have the conversation.
>> A week before their birthday is
substantially different than like an
18-year-old a week after their birthday.
So, let's just not pretend and just say
>> a 36-year-old shouldn't be trying to
either of them.
>> Should fine, but one is legal and one is
illegal. There there actually is a
little bit of
>> That's why I say I don't give a [__]
about legality, Connor. One being legal
doesn't mean it's okay.
>> There is
I I can work with this if we want to not
care about legality for the rest of this
conversation. I'm all down with that.
>> Concerned, I'm sure.
>> But I know someone's going to pull out
legality when it suits them. So
>> both are wrong.
>> Like what the it's wrong on two
accounts. I I think that I think that
when you introduce legality, like that
does affect the morality to some extent
because what somebody can do legally, it
like affects their like like
>> their capacity, right? So if you're an
18-y old,
>> bit of a red flag, right?
>> Well, no, hold on. No, not actually. I
mean capacity in terms of like quite
literally what they can do, right? So if
you think the law is just codified group
morality, which most people do, right?
Your group, your your country, your like
locality, they usually have some idea of
what's right and wrong. And the things
that are really wrong are usually
illegal to some extent. If you believe
that, then constantly cutting against
the group codified morality is probably
indicative of some asocial like
antisocial tendency, right? Like that
seems like a pretty easy uh I don't know
if it's the same guy Jakun. I thought it
was, but maybe you're an 18-year-old,
you can own property, you know, you can
own property, you can uh you know, yeah,
you can you can vote.
>> You can die for your country.
>> You can Yes, you can die for your
country. You can do all these things,
right? Like you have the capacity now to
do all these things. While a
17-year-old, they can't own property,
right? They can't vote. They don't have
participation in our society to the
extent that their birthday is a month
away. Even if their birthday is a month
away. Exactly.
>> Sure. Okay. Fair enough. Um I do um
you've been waiting. I do then lost.
>> Yeah. So Lawson, I mean I asked you to
be coming here because you said that uh
you know these stories blow up, people
make money and then when we find out
that it's not that Destiny is evil or
did something wrong or whatever, nobody
cares about it. But I don't think this
is a case of that, right? So like from
my perspective, this is very obviously
he did a really stupid thing and
continues to do stupid things and
throughout this whole process which
specifically we need to be specific
here. We can't do the I don't want to do
the broad like this is a pattern and
blah blah blah like cuz it's just Yeah.
>> So So the thing I'm talking about is not
it's just not a thing. Can we not do the
nuh-uh and yhu like it's just it's so
stupid and boring.
>> So the thing I'm currently talking about
is the holding on to the uh potential I
think it is like cam um for like 8 n 10
months after he was told that the girl
was 17 years old.
>> Like I think that's ridiculous
obviously. So
>> okay and I assume I assume what you're
saying comes from um like the Willie Mac
that you posted.
>> No not just that. So, I was saying this
earlier, right? So, when I looked at
this girl, like I said, like last
August, right, to figure out who the
[__] this person was and I did see that
she said she was 18 in her bio, right?
So, when they said that this girl had
been found, I looked at Kiwi Farms and
I'm not a Kiwi Farm person to be clear,
but I did look at Kiwi Farms to see if
this was actually the same person that I
saw cuz some people were saying it
wasn't her. I think our relevant said it
was like a twin. I don't know why the
[__] would make any difference. Twin,
whatever.
>> Dubie just throws out. Doobie's like uh
not actually watching all that much. He
just throws out of nowhere.
>> Yeah, they're the same age. Okay. Um
>> twins, but they she just dated for
another sex. Yeah, like stupid. Like,
yeah. So, I looked it up, right? See,
this is the same person I saw. And it is
the same person I saw. This is not This
is absolutely her. And all the other
they found where they found her
birthday. Uh they from like a like a
traffic ticket, some other
>> Yeah. They found like like a bunch of
where she like bliss, right? And
>> there's another piece of documentary
evidence that kind of that like this
person, the person who got docked, that
is 100% a girl who was who was a minor
when Rose was having this conversation
with Destiny. Okay.
>> It see Yeah. Seems very clear. Yeah. At
the time, she was 17 years old.
>> So, yeah. Okay. But I'm talking about
like the the evidence or whatever that
Destiny has CP on his computer.
>> Oh yeah, he Yeah, he
>> uh in the DMs with the Will guy. He said
>> that's what that's what I just said,
bro. Like that's what I'm trying to get
to. So I assuming the the Yeah, the
specific message you're talking about is
um yes, I created copies of all our
messages and everything when that court
case started.
>> Is that really ask him if he has it and
he says yes.
>> He takes a picture of it on his
computer.
>> So here's my question. Um why would
Destiny ever admit this to Willie Mac
knowing who Willie Mac is? He's an
idiot. Why would he do the other [__] he
did?
>> Um, my argument is actually Destiny's
like smart and do you think he could be
as big a political debater if he wasn't
smart? And would a smart people would a
smart person do this? Would a smart
person do this? Really?
>> Actually, this reminds me of something
that I want to get caught.
>> Hold on. I want to get you. Wait, do you
actually believe that?
>> So, so this is like a common uh tactic,
right, of like manipulative people that
Destiny himself laid out once. I
remember seeing and I was like, "Oh,
yeah, that is the thing manipulative
people do. It's like when you get caught
doing a really stupid thing and if the
other person knows you and they think
they think you're an intelligent person,
but you did do the really [__] stupid
thing, you're if you say, "Hey, do do
you really think I would do something
like that? Do you really think I would
do something that's stupid?"
>> But he wasn't caught at all.
>> And that's enough. That's enough to
gaslight people into thinking, "Oh, no,
maybe he didn't actually do this stupid
thing that he wouldn't."
>> This is This guy's about to say
something. He obviously traded videos
with Rose. That's obviously in the logs
to begin with, right? Him soliciting
videos from her. Um, and then once you
find out she's 17, you know that he
solicited videos from her. It's just a
matter of whether or not he still has
the files, whether or not he went to the
cops. But like the fact that he had seam
at some point was already known before
that Willy M call. He's too smart to do
that. But but again and again, Destiny's
been talking really fast.
>> Not the general thing. Stay on stay on
one thing. I'm
>> talking about this one thing.
>> No, but you're saying again and again in
all the Willy Mac that he had this on
his computer. He did.
>> Why are you Why do you keep trying to
frame people's arguments and what
arguments they're allowed to make? Who
is this
>> So before he said, "Yes, I created
copies of all our messages and
everything." What was the proof that
like Destiny had it on his computer? Uh
>> the video title, right? And and hold on.
Prior to the video title.
>> Yeah. The uh name of the file. Hold on.
prior to this um
>> a VLC media player that had the title
that he said was the title of the file
that had the cam. So he had to have seen
the metadata for the file or the file
name had to be shown to him and he had
to see that if he has a screen of Rose
sending him that clip of the of the VC
media player then maybe he can make that
argument. But why wouldn't he have just
produced that?
>> I think this was before the Mac video.
People were saying that um and I don't
mean just randomized people. people that
are associated with Destiny and Dan and
have been in their little circles and
we're able to prove that they were in a
little
>> I need I can't deal with I can't like
>> that's fine I can show you I can show
you later if he's not aware but I can
just tell you right now
>> can you show me now
>> I'd have to pull it I have to dig it up
for you right so I I have been following
this the story right um and I've been
aware of these things so people that
were in these circles these doxing
circles that that Danny Desmond put
together um said that circles
>> noxing no doxing don't do that actively
publicly
>> counterdoxing servers counterdoxing
servers let's not pay any attention to
the fact that they do Sunday and
Hassan's editor in like the same month
let's not do It's not doxing, bro. It's
counterd doxing.
>> Who do pisco dox?
>> What?
>> I don't think he docks anybody.
>> Yeah, they dox Bisco and and the guy
that Hold on. One of the guys involved
said that Dan was one that on the
account that that did it that posted it.
>> Correct. I need to
>> Okay, what do you mean counter doxing?
Like, what do you mean?
>> Hold on, dude. I need to I need to hear
this real quick. You're saying that in
the DG Counterdoc server, they went
after Pisco
>> on Kiwi Farms. They doxed Pisco. Yeah.
And the guy who
>> Did that come from DG?
>> Uh, yes. My understanding is the guy who
said that the guy the guy who
>> Yeah. See, this is the thing is like you
have to sit here if you're a good
person, right? You have to sit here. Oh,
doob. He's not. And maybe I'm not for
even watching this once I knew what it
was. But it seems so it seems like such
that I had to sit here and pretend that
I don't know that this happened and that
somebody aligned with Destiny is not
responsible for it, right? And then I
had to listen to these talk to and
probably tell somebody around Pisco that
it's like, "Oh, it's like it's it's like
Jer Queen's fault that this happened."
It's like, bro, that the guy who did
this doxed a bunch of people who are
like anti- destiny. It's such it's the
counterdoxing that is actually just
aggressive doxing, right? Like they're
the doxers. Uh he said that that the
account that posted Pisco Doc is Dan on
an alt account and he was involved not
just ducks in that guy, but doxing a ton
of other people, right?
Yes. And in the server, um uh they were
posting Destiny was posting images, but
also themselves of this girl when she
was underage to try to so they could
take images from it and try to find her.
and they had to tell him to blur out her
[__] titles because she might be
underage. So, this was recent. So,
obviously he still has has access to
them in some
>> Okay, so Okay, I'm trying not to ping
pong between the docks and and the the
having CP on his computer.
>> Sure, that's fine. You can focus on
>> pick one of the terrible things that you
wish to the alleged terrible things.
>> Okay, hold on. The alleged the alleged
terrible things. What the [__] did Pisco
do that deserve to get doxed for?
>> Well, he didn't get the brand.
This happened when right in the period
where Pis was having all these arguments
with Destiny about all this domination.
I think I think that the day after that
big argument he was dox
>> that sorry dub and just to be clear your
allegation is that with Steven's
knowledge consent whatever uh
>> I don't know if he was he personally was
involved right so it was Dan either you
said some guy said it was Dan's alt
account.
>> Yeah. Okay. The guy that leaked this uh
this doxing server um said that Dan was
was banned at alt. So that's what I'm
saying that I've heard. Right. He was
correct about he was correct about the
other [__] I don't see there's any
reason.
>> Wait. Correct about what? about the
existence of the doxing server that he
was able to prove. He's a provis
>> the doxing server that he said was owned
by Dan through an alt account.
>> No, I think I think it was Dan's like
main account on the doxing server.
>> It was the same one where it was the
same one where they were trying to find
his son's family to smear his family.
>> Like they they were they posted a book
or something written by his father to
try to pull some kind of information
from him that they could use to smear
his father.
>> No, these people were like like Dan
>> this part this part I feel like dubious
from the hip on. I'm a little unaware of
this stuff that I'm aware Dan had a
server where they were trying to dox
like um Niko Sam's dad. Sorry, not
Nikico Sam's dad. Niko Sam was
participating. They were trying to
doxan's dad. But Dan says that that
server was for one of his websites,
right? They're trying to find clips for
his websites and they also just happen
to be using it for um for doxing
Hassan's dad.
>> Well, see when you say smear, I don't
know the difference between smear and
critique.
>> When I say smear, I mean make up about
them. They can use it to tarnish their
public image, right? That's what that's
what I mean by smear.
>> Well, help with that.
>> Who Jaw Who Jaws? Do you know
>> what?
>> Jaw who who he talks.
>> So, that is a huge convoluted web of on
Kiwi farms and well, to be fair, I'm I'm
getting to it, but you've you've come to
me with I think this was Dan's alt
account because some guy said so, but
actually, I think it was his main
account. I like
>> No, hold on. You're misunderstanding.
The the account on Kiwi Farms is an alt
used by Dan. It's the
>> How do you know it's an alt used by Dan?
>> The guy who exposed the doc server.
>> The guy
Dan's computer. I'm not Dan's computer.
I know you have a very high bar for for
Destiny Clans, but but I'm just telling
>> I just want all of us to observe
Lawson's uh bar for Doobie to prove
things, which is appropriate by the way,
>> and we'll see if that that same bar is
appropriate for me or anyone else who
has run a foul of this community. We'll
see if the bar, you know, I believe
based on their other behavior, Wargan
has been publicly he's publicly multiple
people, by the way, on streams, read out
full names and and he's us
process to get somebody's name and
justify him on stream. Like, he's been
doing this for months. Destiny himself
has his full name on it on Twitter.
>> I'm aware of that. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, why are you saying it's
counterdoxing? Insane to say about them.
Like they from Well, first of all, let's
separate Dan from Destiny. Okay. I don't
support everything Dan does.
>> Because they're two people. They're not
one person.
>> Okay. But they're working together on a
project very obviously. They've been for
years actually.
>> What do you mean what project?
>> Destroy games like Destiny's little
attack dog and goes after people. Like
years.
>> No. No. Destiny has said multiple times
on their show that he does not condone
like 90% of what Dan does.
>> Trust. If Destiny can't be held
responsible for the things Dan does, how
can I be held responsible for the things
Kiwi Farms does? How the [__] how the
could I possibly have that? How How can
I be held responsible? No, Kiryoko,
wrong person. I keep telling them this,
but people don't care.
>> And this and this is why he posted the
docs.
>> No, the trustworthy sources. Some guy
told Doobie that this might be Dan's
account.
>> So, you're saying you're saying that
Destiny uh the guy said, "Oh, he doesn't
prove him like all like
>> I agree with that. Should we go into
that one?"
>> So, why so you you just I just tried to
say it's too convoluted and complicated.
Whatever. No, I was I was saying that
and then you said, "Oh, no, it's a
little explain how J."
>> Yeah. So, there is very good reason to
believe that Jtock has has like fostered
his community and supported lots of
people that have basically either dox
Destiny or dox anybody that Well, hold
on.
>> I'm eating the same stuff I was earlier.
Let's see.
>> There's a better way to do it's to
report it to the police.
>> It's not illegal to dox people.
>> Okay. Sorry. Before before you before we
go there. Hi. Quick. Money. Uh $10.
>> You have no more boxing is not crime.
Not Fabian's morality.
>> Alexander at Doobie.
>> Well, you already said that you support.
>> Well, if you call the police, you should
probably give a [__] Fabian, about what
they can do.
>> He's a complete idiot. Then also, how
are you certain on the doxing of school
by DGG?
>> Wait, I don't think he's an idiot.
>> Doxing in and of itself is how you
obtain that information can be.
>> Yeah, it can be, but it's not.
>> Good lord.
>> Right. So, just so if if rape was legal,
would you have a problem with rap?
>> Um, I don't know. Maybe.
>> Okay. Well, get the out of here.
>> I mean, as a DJ, the obvious answer was
no.
>> Actually, question. the clown like no
you're on an exhibit at a zoo that
people come to watch so don't
even does anybody even know what this
weirdo looks like or is he always
looking
>> I know he's very normal looking fair
enough he's very handsome right here
>> very sharp looking guy black one sec one
second just we got a super chat here so
DB do you think Dustin's complete it
then also how certain are you are on the
back of my piece go by DG thank you
Alexander being so kind I hope you're
doing well I haven't seen a but doing
well go ahead
>> okay so no I don't think he's completed
it yet I think that in this specific
sphere when and he feels like he's
attacked. I think he gets very impulsive
and does a lot of dumb [__] right? And
when it comes like very impulsive, does
a lot of dumb [__] I I think that
showing William Mat this right and is I
think even if he didn't have it, just
showing it which would imply to somebody
that you do have access to it is dumb as
there's no reason to to show the video
title or the video name uh to to say,
"Oh yeah, it's really weird to think
that he was uh recording these
underage." There's no reason to show
that, right? Yeah. No reason to show
that to win that. Yeah. So
>> no reason.
>> No reason at all.
>> None.
>> No reason at all. There's nothing gained
from showing the [__] big I don't
know. I'm What was gain from that? Um
well uh Destiny obviously like this guy
solo whatever his name is is probably on
Destiny's top 10 most hated list. So if
he can burn him for having like CP okay
can we agree on this then
from the video title
>> what
>> okay so I understand that it's very
likely that cell is producing cam and
selling it yeah and I think that's what
he found out about the last but let's be
clear what the was the benefit of not
just saying that because there are other
admits that this was the case that he
was they were recording these and that
was underage at the time you don't need
to show the video title so what was the
purpose of show
>> so so what I imagine the purpose to be
is for one do you believe that Destiny
did not think that that sorry not DV
that Willie Mac was going to a video
like right after their conversation.
>> Yeah. What was the purpose of what was
the purpose of the video?
>> Okay. You believe that? Okay. So, if I
were Destiny and I'm talking to Willy M.
>> Yeah. And I'm talking to Willie Mack who
is is allegedly making a video to cover
like drama or whatever cuz that's what
he does. Like here's some more
information about what I know that this
guy probably has on his computer.
>> Okay. Again, there were released last
year I think by Destiny even because
there has conversations between him and
Solo or them released by Solo. I'm not
sure who releases this. Um where Solo
says that she was underage at the time
and in that period and he says underage
at the time these videos were making
were like sex or whatever the [__] That
was released last year. That is that is
all Willie M would need to show. There's
no reason to show the top of a video in
the video title. Absolutely no reason he
did this. So So even the fact that he
did that even if he doesn't have it on
his [__] computer, the fact that he
would do that which would imply to
somebody that he does and then the way
that he answered which was when he was
asked was like, "Oh, depends what you're
asking." And then he gloated reason
hypothetical for why it might be
beneficial to keep it. I think all this
indicates he's a [__] idiot on this
topic. Yes.
>> Okay. Do do you have a do you have a
steel man or strongest argument for why
he would have it?
>> The strongest the strongest argument is
that he genuinely thought for some
reason that his lawyers had instructed
him to hold on to potential cam which I
dearly doubt. I I believe they told no
>> the I mean the strongest argument is he
just didn't want to tell his lawyers
because he might have been scared that
his lawyers might have had a duty to
report it
>> the whole thing the message or whatever
anything put up in discovery but the cam
itself no I I think if he had told him
hey I have a reason to believe this
person is underage I do not believe
Destiny's high price lawyers would have
told him to save that on his computer or
on USB or whatever the [__]
>> and share it on discord messages
>> yeah [__] disc
you need to get get out take it to the
police and and let them follow up on
this because it's like the sale in
production absolutely
>> like someone had blur the video.
>> I will say that almost certainly, okay,
almost certainly I not almost certainly
I've never seen any definitive proof
that the person who was doing like all
the pro DG doxing was Dan. Never seen
anything to indicate that. Okay. Um or
I've never seen anything like credible
or conclusive to indicate that. It's
like one person's like theory that
that's who it is. Um I do think Dan's
been involved in doxing. I don't know
that like that specific person that
they're referring to from the Kiwi Farms
thread is uh is Dan. I have not seen
conclusive evidence of that. So anyway,
just throwing that out there.
>> You have to Someone had to edit the
videos to blur them. No,
>> can I I want to ask a question. Uh
>> with one hand, I'm guessing
>> if we're going to say if we're going to
say if we're going to say um that like
Well, yes, Destiny docs JTO, but Jtock
had it coming because he cultivated a
community that led to other docses. Um,
could Duby not say the exact same claim
about the community that Destiny has
created that led to peace talks?
>> He absolutely could and I would want to
see proof of that.
>> When you say proof of that, like what
what what kind of proof
>> happened? No, no, hold on. Because we're
talking like something much more
nebulous because when it comes to like J
talks, it's very explicit, right? He
doxes him. But the allegation that well,
he deserved it because he cultivated a
community that led some people in the
community to dox some other people.
>> This is like a second this is like a
second order removed consequence down.
I could just simply post I could just
simply send you a video of Destiny being
critical of Pisco and that would be
enough to satisfy the standard.
>> No, so is anybody familiar with JTO's
like server and the the people that he
surrounds himself with?
>> This is also real quick. This was
actually heartbreaking for me because
Jysical was one of my favorite Destiny
orbiters back in the day. And I don't
know if anybody's familiar with the
timeline of when uh got his fully erect
uh Destiny hate, but the timeline is
very convenient with when he started
dating uh Cherry.
>> Wait, no, it's not totally made up
again.
Um,
>> hold on.
>> Oh, hold on. What's up?
>> That is a lie. You are literally no
person's favorite. They are always lying
to you.
>> Thank you. Love you, too.
>> Clear. Cherry. Cherry is the one that
that Destiny recorded her without her
consent. And then
>> that's not even true.
>> How do you know that's not true?
>> How do you know it is true?
>> Okay. Again, so what I'm saying is
Cherry is the one that said that this
that Destiny did this and she has at
least there's at least one. No, I'm
sorry. Hold on. First of all, first of
all,
>> uh, all this Lawson guy would have to do
is come on stream. He's like too scared
to come on stream because he doesn't
want to he doesn't want to actually have
this conversation. That's weird.
>> You guys are gonna You guys are going to
sit here and like flip me because
someone says this guy recorded this
chick without her consent. And I say,
"What's the proof of that? Are you
serious? You want proof of it?" Well,
yeah. Yes. Because defaultly it's not
true until it's proven true.
>> Okay. So So again,
>> okay. So prove that the server is that I
surround myself with people like this or
prove any of this. Lawson, you got to
prove any of this
>> is not how truth work.
>> One second. One second. So my
understanding of the cherry thing is
yeah
>> they'll they'll keep moving forward
without him proving anything right prove
anything bro anything
>> that she was recorded without her
consent apparently multiple times and
this was shared at least I think
>> she didn't say that
>> yes and then there are other people who
have verified that they either received
or or uh those recordings from Destiny
or that uh after she found out she
showed them to show proof that she was
uh that this actually happened and and
then I think the person
>> can we can we zoom in on verified and
which people these are
>> no dude cuz we keep we keeping past what
actually matters
>> I'm on the same thing I'm on the same
Okay, go ahead. So, and then the person
who allegedly got this right um from
Rose's DMs posted a snippet of it on
like Twitter like I think like the first
10 seconds or something, right? So, like
that's that's everything that Terry has
to back up her position and she's
confident she's confident enough that
this is actually true that she filed a
police report. So far, hasn't gotten it
yet, but she's filed a police report. Um
and while Destiny has this, no, not
true. And so, and rather than when I
brought this up, you didn't say that,
oh, we're not sure this or it hasn't
been confirmed. You say no, it's not
true.
>> Yes. Because when someone's accused of
something and they don't like have any
proof for it, yes, my default is it's
not true.
>> You need to like leak her revenge. So
somehow when it goes to Cherry and her
accusations against Destiny, oh, if
there's no proof of it, well, it's not
true. But with Destiny's proof against
me, it's like pictures of cat photos and
pictures of what? People mocking him in
my server. And that's proof. It's uh
what is it? Us talking with the the
exclamation point at the end. That's
proof. Is this guy out of his mind?
>> And tiles today. So
>> how would she prove this to you?
>> What? How would she prove this?
>> How would she prove that she was
recorded without Well, how does she know
she was recorded without her consent?
>> Because she has copies of the recording.
Okay, that would be a start.
>> You want copies of the [__] recordings?
>> Well, well, dude,
>> is it DG or I I don't know what else to
say?
>> You understand? You're asking for a
standard that would no one would ever
accept ever.
>> What do you understand that?
>> No, dy. I have recordings of you outside
my window videotaping me jacking off and
I didn't know you were there. I have
them though.
>> So, where do we go? Where do we go from
here?
>> We have four people.
>> What people? Okay, this is why I wanted
to stop you because what people are you
talking about
>> and what names every single name ever
interacted with the situation? Yes,
that's why I asked you [__]
>> Alexander win.
>> So I would say is Lawson like super
uh
>> he says he says uh $10 I says she was
not record
>> uh no this is also wrong Alexander Ren
she was recorded without her consent
>> without her consent. It was shared
without her consent
that's not the claim could be wrong. the
claim could be wrong, but that's not the
thing. The claim is that she was
recorded without her consent and it was
shared without her consent and she
learned of the recording because of the
Yeah, it was audio recording. Um, that
she learned of the recording because of
it being shared.
>> Well, because of it being doxed from
being shared,
>> paying to By the way, these embarrassing
are massive pay pigs. The Alexander guy,
the Lawson guy, the Lawson guy is the
biggest pay pig. I don't want this loser
back in my community. He is
embarrassing. Okay? I don't care how
much money he spends. He donates 100
bucks, 200 bucks to Wick at the drop of
a hat. This loser, get him the away from
me. That is the claim,
>> right? Okay. So, again, they're like, I
think uh Queen um Jaw uh that the girl's
name. Um one of the ones that said she
received it. I forgot her name, but she
wasn't in J's crew, if that's what
you're thinking. Uh she said on Twitter,
Twitter that she received it, she told
Cherry about it. I forget her [__]
name. It's like um is it like Abby or
something? I can't remember her [__]
name, but there's like three or four
people that three or four people who
said they've seen this, right? Um and
that it exists and that it's real,
right? So, and given his this the other
behavior that was that was made uh
public at the time, which is sharing of
people's news and show without consent
and recording people recording audio of
people very uh which one audio stop.
Wait, can don't please don't pile stuff
on one at a time. Please,
>> by the way, this guy's like super down
to debate this. I've offered him to come
on stream. I've said, "Bro, come on
stream like a hundred times. Why is he
terrified to get on my stream? Why'd he
hop on the stream with these people? Why
would he have hopped on? I was so nice
to this guy in DMs. You have no idea.
all the reasons, but I think it's it's
very likely that it's true. Okay, more
likely than that, it's true. So, one of
the other reasons is that there was
another recording that was released of
him with some dude that was just audio
and he took it in his pocket, right? And
oh, well, some people get nervous and
when this was brought up, it's like, oh,
some people get nervous with the camera
so I recorded in my pocket. That's
[__] nonsense. I'm sorry. Like, no.
So, um, so I just I think it's very
likely that based on all this, right,
and probably some other things I'm
forgetting right now that that this
happened to Cherry and he did this,
right? So, so Destiny's response of this
is no, not true. Then, yeah, I have no
reason to believe him about this one
because he's lied about so many other
things.
>> This is a different different
allegation. None of them are true.
>> Which ones are true? Me? All of them. I
think.
>> All of them. You think? Hold on. Wait.
Hold on. Do you think that I'm wrong
about him lying about so many other
things? Like
>> Well, maybe. Wait, I need specifics.
>> Oh my god.
>> Well, dude, don't give me this. Oh my
god. This is This is the problem I have.
Look, this is why. Look, Dooby. Doobie,
I've done this. I've had the same
conversation against DJs about you, how
Dubby's a Nazi, and Doobie said this and
Doobie said that, and they just keep
piling on and nobody and nobody ever
wants to go into like the details of
why. They just want to say, "Wow, you
want to argue about this one thing even
though we know all this other [__] about
this person when a lot of the other
shit's not true either." And that's
what's happening.
>> Hold on. Hold on. I don't even
>> I every one of these people just gets
away from this idea that you have to
prove some association between my
community and Kiwi Farms to like even
make this argument, right? Some some
association, by the way, that I'm that
I'm aware of and enforce and am against
moderating, right? Like that's what you
have to argue because obviously
individual people could come in and like
post something and I would, you know,
moderate that and there's nothing I can
do to control that, right? But you have
to make you have to make this argument
and say that it's something that I
refuse to moderate that I encourage that
I've like perpetually had which is
crazy.
>> Even need the other pattern the rest of
the patterns of dishonesty.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> Unless you want to go through each one.
>> This is just No, no, no, no. This is the
meta,
>> right? This is No, this is it's
important to do the meta. Like what we
have here is we have I'm assuming some
cult member um that can't accept reality
because he's too in love with the
concept of Destiny and DGG. But but but
I'm working with insufficient evidence.
That's just my first assumption. And
there's this tactic where you're trying
to establish several things as a
pattern. He wants to go through each
one, present a different
counter-argument, and muddy the waters
with each thing because he doesn't want
to deal with the overarching narrative
that he's already accepted, which is
that Destiny is an immoral degenerate,
right? Because which is
>> I'm actually rubber in your glue. So,
checkmate. Go on, Die.
>> No, wait. I don't ask. I don't ask like
you're talking about like going like one
one by one.
>> Well, yeah, because I very quickly
however quickly we can do it. What is
the What is the sufficient evidence here
that Jtock was personally involved in
doxing people that would give
>> Yes. Oh, Lactoid. Beautiful. I always
say this, Lacto is a fantastic debater.
I understand a lot of people don't like
him for some reason, but he is a really
good debater and he's actually good at
pointing out like, hey, this is the
thing that's like like this this is the
premise that you are most weak on, like
you are most vulnerable on, and this is
the premise I'm going to keep hammering.
>> It would be right to for death to
destiny to dox him.
>> Jtock was personally directly.
>> Remember, JTO was the one who was doxed
and so what did he do to justify that to
be clear?
>> Yes, I I believe it was counterdoxing.
>> Okay, so what did he do? All right, let
me pull it up. Hold on.
>> He had a community of people who hated
Destiny and doxed them and therefore
should suffer the crimes of his
community.
>> Can I post in uh prime? I've never used
stream blast
>> and the discord. Yeah, the discord group
DM.
>> All right. I just want on record I'm
going to post evidence before Jimmy did
just on record.
>> Oh god.
>> Noted for don't go me. Don't go me.
>> I'm going to point I'm going to point
out the different standard that I'm
being
>> he's getting fed from Destiny. I don't
care who he's getting fed from. Listen,
I keep getting told that I'm guilty of
this, right? I keep getting told this
over and over again. If they have some
evidence and something I can action on,
then I'd love to action on it and show
them that I don't want this. This isn't
something I want. And by the way, even
if they have evidence now, I've asked
repeatedly. You have to show me some
kind of evidence of something so I can
moderate it because I don't support
this. But instead, they like hold all of
this evidence back and they're like,
"Well, here's some people talking about
how Destiny looks weird in this picture.
That's evidence." No, it's not
disliking. Guess what? Disliking ev
disliking Destiny is not a doxable
offense. If you're trying to create the
a world where thinking Destiny is a
disgusting loser is worth doxing someone
over, you you are a loser. Okay? Like
it's so insane that that's clearly what
they're trying to do. If you think
Destiny's a disgusting loser and you
want to say that a lot, um we should be
able to dox you. Actually, you're like
basically a Kiwi farmer and uh we should
be able to dox you. You you should get
dox.
>> Hey, hey, Scott, while he's while
Lawson's working on that, um what would
be wrong? I mean, like from like an
argumentative stance to do what he was
what he's doing, right? He's saying,
"Hey, you're presenting you're
presenting a lot of data, right? You're
telling me all these things, but like
unless we establish that these
individual um instances are actually
true, then the overarching narrative is
untrue." What would be wrong?
>> There's nothing there's nothing wrong
with isolating argument.
>> Is anybody in a server with Lactoid so I
can add him on Discord? Cuz I would love
to add him and just ask like, "Hey,
could you just tell me like what they
posted? Is it like Lactoid TV?" No. I'm
going to try to add Lactoid and I'll see
if it's got the same uh Does it have
like the same It's got the same thing.
We'll see if this guy adds me. Yeah,
that's that's that's him. Mutual
friends, mutual servers.
>> Yeah, I got him. Hold on.
>> You mentioned handling them one at a
time. There is something wrong with
isolating arguments one at a time and
then attempting to introduce new counter
arguments that move into a different
direction and subvert the conversation
so that Doobie has to try and regain
control of the conversation so that
we're on some relevant topic and then
constantly subverting with one at a time
so that the conversation turns into
nothing because you notice we haven't
gotten anywhere on anything. And it's
mostly because you brought on this
stupid clown to just act like a stupid.
>> You're right, baby. You guys are making
hell of progress before I got here on
getting to the bottom of things. Okay.
Uh, but well, thank you for answering
that. I mean, all right, that's it's an
answer. Um, I just love to see this,
man. I just want to see it. Could I see
it? Oh, did this just crash again? Dude,
I'm going to lose it.
>> I'm like, I'm 30.
>> YouTube YouTube is straight up dog right
now. I don't know what's going on that
is, right? So,
>> you can nobody and nobody ever wants to
go into like the details of why. Hold
on. He had a community of people who
hated Destiny and Dustin these things
but like unless we establish that
nothing because you notice
>> crazy
>> haven't gotten anywhere on anything and
it's mostly because you brought on this
stupid [__] clown to just act like a
stupid
>> right you guys are making hell of
progress for I got here on getting to
the bottom of things.
>> Okay. U but I thank you for answering
that. I mean All right. That's an
answer. Um
>> look I I I look I don't this is black.
Wait one thing. This is this is where I
sympathize with you guys because this is
exhausting. This is something that does
take like hours and hours and hours
because it all goes back to like the
Anavoir and like the like 15-year-old he
said was hot like eight years ago and
like other like it
>> I don't shut the [__] up and post the
evidence, bro. Take as much time as you
want, but shut the [__] up and post the
evidence. This is all we're here for.
>> It is exhausting. So, I will uh you
know, I will cut you some slack on that.
There's there's also and like I said I
think it's good to go like and that's
why I asked you specifically about the
JTOK thing just because you know when I
saw the fact that they doxed him and I
also the death threats and everything I
thought this was like pretty extreme
like this was sort of crossing the
Rubicon in terms of just kind of like I
didn't think a streamer this big would
be doing stuff like this like this is
pretty wild right um but to give like a
little bit of uh credit here as well
like when you have somebody who has such
a long history as Destiny does in this
space you can't like especially like on
a panel like this where we got what
three hours three and a half hours we
can't possibly go in depth on every
single one of these
>> right sometimes you just have to likely
mention Right? And you say, "Look, this
is like part of pattern behavior. Don't
you remember XYZ?" And you could say,
"Well, but let's like go into XYZ." We
don't have time to go into XYZ. I mean,
Xone is right. So,
>> but you can you can go into X though and
>> potentially
my theory as to why this was done was
because I think that J was threatening
the brand. But also, this kind of
behavior is like particularly egregious.
Like as streamers or even just internet
people, I think that all of us would be
pretty or I guess maybe are pretty
terrified of somebody who's dramatically
more powerful than us putting in
resources into doxing us and making
death threats to us. That kind of scared
me a little. I'll tell you right now.
I'm doxed. I'm finding the person who
doxed me and going to them like
directly.
>> Okay.
>> But you're not going to break through
the noise.
>> Oh god. No.
>> Look, I've done this. I've had the same
conversation
>> or even
>> I'm so I think that all
power
>> this guy this guy's crazy to say that.
Jesus Christ.
>> I'm sorry. Like this is part of like I
power dynamics are usually like memes,
right? But there is something here as to
like if a multi-millionaire is trying to
come after you and you're not that
you're kind of at a huge disadvantage.
>> Yeah, leftist power dynamics are
actually completely correct. Not just
memes. Um but anyway, uh Fairy Queen,
FQ. Um that's a nice picture of you
right there.
>> No, Fairy Queen, stop donating money to
get him off track. Fairy Queen
>> um says, "Ask Lawson how Destiny knows
that Rose had with like 10 different
guys in the video." Um which he says in
the Willy Mack DMs if he didn't possess
or view the CP on his computer. Uh, so
Lawson,
>> first of all, fairy queen, love you,
miss you. Hope you're doing good. Um,
I'm sure he saw them. I'm I'm my my
contention is not Destiny never viewed I
mean what's what's probably now child.
>> Well, it was CP Thin, too.
>> Sure. Yeah. I'm just saying like I'm
sure he did.
>> Whether or not he whether or not he knew
is is, you know, up for the mysteries of
the universe, right? Like I mean maybe
he knew, maybe he didn't know that. Like
>> the contention is whether or not he kept
it.
>> Um, we don't have proof that he still
has it on his computer, guys.
>> He handled it responsibly. What's the
percentage chance of it being CP? Like
99% 99.8% 99%. Like 95% maybe. Maybe I
can bring it back a little bit. 95%
chance.
>> He clearly either didn't handle it
responsibly at all or he's just lying to
people to like so that he can because
he's a 5D chess genius and then later
he'll show that he did actually handle
it responsibly and that it was
>> that's that's the thing is like this
this is like the cope, right? What
Fabian's laying out right here is people
are like, "No, you don't understand.
Like he might just be baiting people."
It's like baiting people into think he's
a
this guy like he's actually if that were
actually the case. If he were like
baiting people and think he's a he's
worse than a I don't know what is worse
than a but it's whatever Destiny would
be if he was like doing some kind of 5D
chess to make other people look stupid
by baiting them to calling him a that
would be insane.
>> All lies and smoking mirrors. Um, I mean
like there, you know, I could sprout
wings and fly potentially, but all of
the available evidence that we have
points to the fact that he is wildly at
at minimum is a dude in his mid-30s
constantly going after teenagers and not
really giving a underage or not um in
any real way and is using his power and
influence to try and um, you know,
garner that, maybe make some careers
and, you know, um, and and that's a
[__] problem. And then when people
reach out to him, he is wildly handling
this wrong and is maintaining um,
childborn on his computer for some
reason. Um, and that this is a a
relative pattern of behavior, not
necessarily the CP, but in constantly
being involved in drama and in bullying
and in potential um,
>> destroying these teams lives, these
20-year-olds lives.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, I mean, he's made a few
20-year-olds lives, too, to be fair. Um,
but, uh,
>> but I mean, that's what you get when you
go with Destiny. You got to roll the
dice whether or not your life is ruined
or whether or not you get a career. And
he's, you know, you know, it's kind of
like a Harvey Weinstein, you know, maybe
if you just bend over on the on the on
the couch,
>> except on a long enough time scale,
everybody's life is ruined, right? Like,
who's known this guy long term?
other than Dan who's independently
wealthy before he met Destiny who's
known this guy in like a long enough
term and their life hasn't been with
significantly basically right like
there's there's basically like maybe you
could argue V although from what I
understand V and Molina's relationship
that was pretty and both of them had a
pretty up experience with each other
right Moot uh I think Moot had some
pretty bad experiences with Destiny's
community I maybe that comes up to a
wash Bose Bose ended up you know
exploding her own platform so true but I
I am saying that like there are not very
many people who interact, stay around
longterm, and aren't like somehow within
the end.
>> Ouch for them, you can have a career in
this industry.
>> Oh, no. Um, Alexander win $5 says, "My
apologies if they can't fix it. No
problem. Um, we all mistakes. Not a big
deal." Sorry, there's so many.
>> Another 19-year-old like it's just Well,
even if they once again, I think it's
morally disgusting to be skirting like
you're you're 36. You're scrolling
Discord for 18, 19year-old.
>> You know what? I'm I am ecstatic that we
can all land on mild social conservatism
being the right way to conduct your
personal affairs. I'm happy we all agree
on that.
>> Just being a norm, bro. I wanted to talk
about that counter points um because I
had a larger conversation with someone
else offline about uh this uh very issue
um and and we just don't have time to
get it because it's going to be inflamm
it's going to be extremely inflammatory.
Um but u I I I I I think that okay very
very quickly right um I think it's
there's something to be said about
people who uh tend to have like a
prediliction for those who are much
younger than them right um like and they
like establish a pattern um like that
type of person that sounds like a red
flag to me right nothing else that
sounds like a red flag
>> liberals and progressives looks like a
paraphilic right so here's here's
actually part of my beef because because
I actually do have
>> am I the only one uh am I the only one
who's sitting here like uh this lost
Harrison guy posted nothing he's not
posted anything yet. Can I Can I find Is
this guy serious? He was just arguing
it's counterdoxing. He knows it's
counterdoxing. How does he know it's
counterdoxing when he when he doesn't he
hasn't presented any evidence? Where's
the evidence? Where's the evidence?
Where's the evidence?
>> A I don't know 30% 40% crossover with
DG. Okay. And and this is my beef. So,
liberalism maximum human liberty. Uh
effectively like it doesn't really make
a prescription past the age of 18. It
says like, "Oh, you're an adult. Pursue
your happiness." And actually when you
make a whole bunch of Conor saying that
nobody cares about
>> a series of like millionaire women,
right, who who are otherwise amazing and
completely compatible with him, right?
And could it be the love of his life?
But he says no because they have as much
power as I do, right? And power.
>> No, no,
it is more ethical to be gay.
>> That's that's that's interesting because
sexism. Let me let me just just get out.
Let me just get out the thesis. Okay.
Right. um is that like just because you
happen to uh be involved with a person
where there's a power some sort of power
imbalance does not necessarily tell me
on its face that there's a problem right
if there's a larger pattern that's
different right or if I can see inside
this relationship if I can examine it
and examine the the mechanisms of that
relationship people but I think people
do
inherently evil in that regard
>> the literally the only thing I tuned
into this for was uh was just watching
this part just the part where this guy
postes evidence
>> I think the the problem um what I would
say is that you know it's Even in even
in a power dynamic, it's not necessarily
a power dynamic, but there's a problem.
The problem is does the person that is
in the the submissive or the subservient
or the lower
capitalize on that so you can take
advantage of their inexperience so you
can get access to cheap gratifying.
I'm also I'm also Let's also be honest.
If you're constantly looking at the
18-year-olds and that's who you're
targeting, if the law was 17, we all
know that they'd be waiting until they
turn 17.
I I'm just saying this Lost and Harrison
guy said it was counterdoxing and he
feels confident it's counteroxing. He
there is evidence. He has to have the
evidence. If he thinks the evidence is
in Destiny's VOD of Destiny saying he
proved it, you are you are
okay. And I I think this guy should be
enough of a non-coward to come and admit
that he doesn't have that evidence.
>> Me, too. But this expand this expands
into a moral prescription, by the way.
And people keep saying like, "Oh, you
have no morals. You have no principles."
I've been with my wife for 13 years. I
haven't had any other emotional or
physical relationships with any other
person in that entire time. I have two
children. I'm a relatively
>> pretty emotional between us. I don't
know.
>> But but that's more like a fraternal
love than a love cry. So any
you have may have personal morals. I
think people are just people myself
included calling you out for willing to
to willing to work with people that
don't have those morals.
>> But I think that but I think that
especially in this space though um I I
think that Fabian, you and I are the
only person that are married and have
kids.
>> I'm married and have kids.
>> Well, I'm married. I'm married and I
will have a kid in March.
>> Oh, actually Dubie does as well. Okay.
All right. Hold on. Duby's marriage is a
marriage. Only people.
>> You know what? You know what? I stand
corrected. I'm just kidding. I love you.
>> I would forward the argument that two or
three years ago, it's actually kind of
funny how time changed things. Uh two or
three years ago, 70% 80% of Twitch poll
panels were 100% like,
>> you know, 18 to 30year-olds who were
promiscuous, respect workers, who were
single, family, and all that.
>> Jesse isn't an out of control party boy.
He's more like a flasher on the street
corner. The violation is is the turn on
in that of itself.
>> Girl knows about inappropriate. That's
for goddamn sure.
>> Destiny isn't an out of control party
boy. He's more like a flasher on the
street corner. The violation is the turn
uh on the the violation is the turn on
in that of itself.
>> Okay. Okay. Can I can I respond to Queen
after Conor?
>> Well, yeah. If I if I can be brief.
Wait, I brought this last somebody's
breaking up. Uh so I brought this like
rubbing his hands together.
>> This is the this is the danger of the
hyonic treadmill. Okay. If you're
unfamiliar with the concept, go ahead
and take a look at it.
>> Yourself, Conor, you get your money.
>> Um, actually, if you give into
degeneracy, then you'll just seek more
degeneracy in an infinite loop and then
you become a worse person. But I'll keep
supporting this person unconditionally
with no changes on their part because it
makes me money yourself in a video game.
Don't actually do it. I don't want to
break the TOS. Okay.
>> Over the years and bring back all black
everything. I would actually love to.
Um, we just need more reliable guests.
It's really the long and short of it.
>> Like Connor, all Connor needs to do just
show up to these things and say, "I
don't care who he hurts. He makes me
money. It's way shorter. You save us all
a whole bunch of time and we don't care
about. We understand that you've
justified this to yourself. Go ahead.
Justify to nobody cares, right? Just
say, "I I don't care how much he hurts
people. I'm going to let him keep doing
that as long as it makes me money."
That's all you got to say, Connor. Stop
pretending to like have some moral
grounding to this. You don't.
>> If I had more black people to bring in
the space and have him be able to come
on week after week, I would absolutely
do it.
>> He is available and it's something to
consider. and do and do. Oh my god, we
had a whole thing about this already
that right. So, so at some point, you
know, if you're not committed in a
monogous relationship, which I
understand if it's the ideal for me,
it's not the idea, etc. as he's as
>> I never contested that.
>> Yes, you did. You asked me. You asked
me.
>> Okay, finally. These guys are
>> Sorry, I've been switching between like
show.
>> Oh, my bad. I provided as much proof as
everyone else did. Oh, so he didn't he
come at Dubbie and say, "Oh, just for
the record, I'm like giving more proof
than Duby, dude. I'm giving proof before
Dubie." And he's given nothing.
You're saying okay hold provide some
kind of proof. Okay. And that is yes.
Okay. It's in the group cam. So when
he's asked by Willie Mac uh if you're
sending me this I'm guessing you still
have that video. His response is oh
guess why? It depends on what you're
asking. And then but yes I created a
copy. Yada yada yada. So like he's asked
he's asked
>> I never contested that.
>> Yes you did. You asked me why.
>> Oh why do you believe he stole his cam
on his computer? Yes. You contested
that. You literally asked why Duby
believes he stole the cam.
>> You ask me what proof I have that he saw
the video.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I don't know. Is that he had
the video?
>> Collection child porn. But I'm telling
you, he's he that he still had the video
when he responded to J to Willie Mack.
He said, "Yes, I had it." Like that.
That's what he said.
>> Okay. C can we agree that that uh Willie
Mack did call the police? Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm guessing the police take child
fairly seriously.
>> I hope so.
>> I hope so. Which you are
experiences over the years. In fact, I
report.
>> Yeah. He just slips the cops a h 100red
when they come in and they don't care
about CP anymore. Um yeah. So, I imagine
if he did get the police called on him
that I don't think he would have
streamed today if that were the case.
>> Okay. So, hold on. So, have you gone
from uh you know, we we shouldn't we
shouldn't think we shouldn't think that
he actually had this on his computer to
uh well, he hasn't been charged with
anything that we're aware of, so we
should just trust him. Like I said,
>> well, I'm I'm operating from the
assumption that Destiny isn't a complete
idiot. And if he did have that on
>> Unfortunately, this guy, listen, I love
Rei. Unfortunately, this guy watched
Rey's argument. Guys, I'm operating from
the B point of view that like Destiny's
maybe not a complete and um yeah, I'm
operating from that point of view. Why?
Why? Why would you operate from that
point of view? Sounds pretty dumb.
>> At this point, because he's just because
he's not. And I don't believe you
believe that he is either.
>> Hold on. I do think Hold on. On this
issue, interpersonal
>> here. Here's the thing. I think
Destiny's pathological. Is he a complete
in every aspect of his life? Obviously
not. But he keeps making decisions that
make no logical dissense. uh no logical
sense in this realm. There is something
pathological going on. Something is not
engaging logically in his brain before
he goes and does things. Right. The and
the better proof of this honestly better
proof than just telling Lily Mack that
you have child on your computer which is
already maybe the most thing Destiny's
ever done. But there is something more
and that is while you're trying to spin
a narrative that all of your ops are
connected to kiwi farms and they're the
reason people get doxed, you provide
doxing information while taunting the
same kiwi farmers you're trying to tie
to other people by taunting those same
people saying take this information and
try to dox her. You give a bunch of doc
a bunch of PII about that person who is
the minor you sent to Kiwi Farms so that
they can dox her. Which one of those two
decisions leads you to believe that
Destiny's decision-making in this realm
is not tainted, is not broken? Because
both of those two decisions are
completely insane.
>> And his weirds on the other
would an intelligent person share uh
someone's news with with somebody that
they just met uh with in under a week.
Would an intelligent person do that? I
would say no. He did that.
>> Yeah, maybe.
>> Yeah.
What? Is that is that is that a stupid
thing to do or is that a reckless thing
to do or is that
>> the implication would be that it's not
an intelligent thing to do? The By the
way, the implication that intelligent
people don't make bad decisions is also
stupid.
>> If we if we if we go off of what fairy
queen was saying, right? We assume this
to be true. I'm not saying this is true,
right? I'm just offering a possibility.
We go off of the concept that Destiny is
in a situation where he is addicted to
the drama, addicted to the kind of the
the the fear of getting caught, addicted
to doing the perverse, then it is per if
if we assume that to be part of the
paraphilia that that is that is
enrapturing Destiny's experiences. Um,
then it's perfect. Yeah, I said assume
like seven times, right? Allegedly. Fair
enough, right? Um, yeah. No. Then then
it's perfectly reasonable to assume that
Destiny can be a I mean, it's not
reasonable to assume that he's like
super smart, but that he can be in a
slightly above average IQ person or
like, you know, 115 IQ, whatever metric
in that area you want you want to grab
and still engage in very stupid behavior
in those instances because they would be
wrapped up together. Just like just like
a a streaker, just like a flasher,
right? the idea that they're like ooh
the idea of getting caught or oh yeah I
have like there's it's not unreasonable
that he might do stupid things in terms
of showing what people what he has
because his his paraphilia both both of
these things can actually you know the
potentially danger queen was looking for
>> are moral but if I created my
entertainment to match my morals I'd be
significantly less which I really
appreciate so much she says do you think
Ted Buddy Ted Bundy attacked the sort of
girls at Florida State because what
would degenerate
>> yeah that also
>> well I need to leave in a moment so I'll
answer briefly degenerate 150 years ago
um was actually understood as a
statement about life where if you engage
in good behavior. I'll secure the
station.
>> Actually, 150 years ago, degenerate
meant something totally different than
what fairy queen means here or anyone
means when we actually talk about it.
And uh I'm just going to throw that out
there cuz it's really important that I
do that cuz I got to go right away.
Also, I'm going to lift some more
weights. Just give me a second. Dude, do
I provide facts relevant to the findings
regarding details of the event destin
format with confidence to me. Um so,
thank you Audacity um for that
attestation. Thank you for the kind $10.
Okay. Um
>> I'll answer the question enough for me.
So I I will say this because maybe he
was regarded towards me towards me. I
don't know. I will say that Ted Bundy um
may have engaged in those attacks due to
degenerate um behavior. I will agree
with points to some degree. I mean
predominantly primarily it's because
he's you know as ASPD, right? He was a
psychopath, right? I mean as a
personality disorder and what what
causes personality disorders is is a
subject for a lot of debate even even in
in like there's a lot there. Um but I
would say that there are What are you
doing? What is that noise?
>> Sorry, I apologize. I keep my Don't
worry about it.
>> Wait, what is Fairy Queen talking about?
What? I don't even What? How did that
make any sense?
>> I was thinking it, but I wasn't going to
say it. I didn't want to go there for
the memes, but
>> hopefully that's not please.
>> It is a real job. Jewish.
>> I have a real job. Put on my hands.
>> I should know white people. I don't know
where you
>> It's not. Remember, it's not racist if
it's targeted towards white people.
>> Excuse me. Jeez, not white. First of
all, that's not what I said. I will not
let that stand. I didn't say that.
>> Black save us by having sex.
>> 18-year-old specifically, but young
people, legal adults. Okay. Legal adults
as a young people. Yeah. And my question
is like very like uh it's very
straightforward, right? It's based on
the premise of like if someone can [__]
me up, why can't I [__] You're telling
me that this person is so impressionable
and easily manipulated that like you
know I can't like get with them yet
they're able to like decide my fate on
the political level. They can vote
they're both equal to mine. The
>> problem is you [__] people over like
in a revenge way I don't
like they're so easily manipulated like
manipulated that like they can't even
have sex like 18 years old and then they
shouldn't be able to decide what we'll
actually I disagree with some other
people who are like oh we should raise
>> look I think this is a good opportunity
for you. There's college money there.
You didn't get good grades and like you
kind of straight
>> I'm like I'm just trying to
>> look it. The only time this will occur
is if the not libertarian okay anyway.
Um, before you leave, yeah, before you
leave, I had a question for the panel
that I want to answer to. So, you have
two choices, gentlemen. One is a
16-year-old Amish girl. The other is a
30-year-old woman inhabitant of North
Central Island.
>> Make your choice.
>> I get the only one who gets this. Okay.
North Island is like a super remote
island with like a tribal peoples that
are like gener.
Yeah. Yeah. And they just discovered
fire.
>> Okay. I'm not going to give you the
clip. I got to go to bed. By the way,
yeah, sure. Okay. My name's Connor. I
run down the wonderful war. It's
fantastic. Go check out. It's my most
successful channel. I'm also trying to
count politics and val network.
Counterpoints politics. Just Google Just
find out all the information I can find
now. We know these public doc just I'm
not aware of anybody that a dox there's
no evidence that they can connect to any
do himself and Daniel himself having
doxing people. We know this.
>> Yeah. I understand.
>> So I don't understand. Okay. So why
would they call it counterdoc if it were
shown to you that Jessica was doing what
I claim he is doing? Would that make a
difference?
>> Yeah of course it would make a
difference. Would make a difference. But
also but also why do you believe it when
you don't have the evidence? You can't
even describe it. Just describe the
evidence that makes you think this.
Please describe any of the evidence. Uh,
hey unrelated. Veto put out his comic a
couple days ago. Lots of good reviews
all over Twitter for him. Uh, the only
review I've seen is from Derson himself
and says it's Cherry. So, I trust on
this one. Okay. I trust unfortunately.
Uh, he said that Veto's comic is dog. I
have no idea why he'd do that to his
co-host. Seems kind of up. The only
thing I've seen is is talking and going,
"Look, look. He plagiarized the gun. He
plagiarized the gun."
Is a hater for a living.
is a hater. He is. He's a dick.
>> Okay. But all you're saying is that he
cultivated a community where people were
doxing uh Hutch. So far we know. Um but
if if that's
>> dude I want this Lost guy to come I I so
badly want him to come on stream right
now.
>> If that's a standard Well, Destiny
himself and Dan himself were publicly
saying they're going to dox people while
the community was trying to dox people
and saying doxing base yada yada. So
like if that's a standard, how the [__]
is that counter? The person, again, I'll
say the person who actually originated
Hutch's docs is somebody who was in
Dan's server discussing doxing Hassan
Piker's dad. That they're the same guy.
They're the same guy. The person who
originated Hutch's docs is the guy who's
in Dan's server trying to dox Hassan
Piker's dad. And that gets blamed on me
somehow. You come to you come to me and
blame that on me. What
>> if if what say a community being
cultivated where people were doxing
Hutch, right, so far? How is how is it a
counterdox when Destiny himself and Dan
himself are involved in organizing
doxing at the times of people?
>> Because like Okay, trying to think of
how to how to phrase this. Sorry for
>> think this hard brother.
>> Well, it's difficult. Looking
I need to post this really quickly. Um
because the guy who um the script that I
just posted where the guy talks about
docsing President Sunday at Dan's
direction, President Sunday um
acknowledged that that same guy called
Niko Sam I think it is reached out to
him directly and apologized for that
like like months prior, right? So,
President Sunday believes that this guy
was involved in his docks and this guy
is admitting publicly that he was
involved in the docks at Dan's right.
>> Dan's direction.
>> Yes.
>> And what what guy is it?
>> A guy called Niko Sam, I think it is.
>> And who is that?
>> Do we believe that Lost Harrison is a
Destiny super fan? Does have has no idea
who Nikico Sam is. That's like a little
Dude, he he also said he's a big fan of
mine. Like, did he miss the whole Tom
Foolery thing as well? I don't know if I
believe that. Do we believe that? I
don't know if we believe that. Okay. So,
he's uh one of the people that was
involved in the Kiwi farms. I'm posting
doces on Kiwi Farms. Um doces of people
that were like anti-destiny basically. I
think the one the specific one he talks
about is the is president Sunday and um
and also the Hassan docs group and I
posted the Hassan docs group about that.
>> Oh, Nico Sam by the way.
>> Okay.
>> Uh Alexander win while we're waiting on
that. Uh $10. Libertarians and HayQ are
a lot like leftist morality or
conservatives in Christianity. They
never shut up about it and you the
stories. Um but they're nowhere to be
found. Um thank you Alexander Win for
the kind uh $10. Yeah, I bring it up all
the time.
>> The lacto likes to bring that up. Um,
and uh, a leftist in morality. Do I
talk?
>> I think uh, me and Cory went over it.
Cory, you would agree that uh,
libertarians have very high accuse
compared to they do score pretty low in
empathy. Um, but they do have very high
accuse.
>> Uh, yeah. As in I would agree with that.
Uh, I personally would not take the
trade-off with empathy. Personally,
>> did he leave?
>> No.
>> I mean, it is midnight. It is past
midnight. It's like
>> But I mean, he was in the middle of uh,
you know, reading this.
>> It could have been an accident.
So, what's what's what's uh what's your
line for for like when when when does
Trump do too much to piss you off?
What's the line for you? I want to know
cuz I keep seeing you on Twitter
defending yourself in that like, yeah,
I'll call him out. I'll criticize the
I'll criticize the
>> I know you do, but like you know, much
to like, you know, like people who are
on Destiny side, like how much bull are
you going to have to be embarrassed by
before you're like, "Hey, you know what?
Maybe it was just a bad choice."
>> Look,
>> what's the line for you? You want to
know what
>> Lawson guy leaves.
>> I don't know exactly where the line is.
I'll give you a list of a couple things
that he could do. Yeah. Well,
>> he returns.
>> Trying to I'm trying to get this guy to
come on the stream. Okay. Trying to get
this guy to get on
>> a full IQ test for those cognitive
ability tests for the research that
you're doing.
>> I think I think that IQ I think that IQ
tests are some of the most means tested
tests in all throw out.
>> You know which one I'm talking about?
So, in order to get into it, you have to
be verified.
>> Boots on the ground using the flimsiest
of excuses to uh send military troops
into other American cities. That's not a
line for you. He's talking about
Chicago. He's talking about
Philadelphia. talking about he's talking
about specifically Chicago is next on
the list. He already did Los Angeles,
right? Um so
>> it depends. It depends what it's for. If
he does with LA where the there's
federal uh troops because that's what
they were
>> uh federal troops that were there to
protect
>> I don't have uh I don't have Streamyard
set up. I just want their job federally.
>> You're saying they did nothing but
you're right. Yeah. If if you're telling
me is my line if they send feds that do
nothing.
>> That's not a line for me. They do
something really bad then that could be
a line.
>> Okay. All right. Well, I I'll leave that
there. I won't make this whole thing
about that. Alexander win for $10. Um,
Corey, don't you know anytime it's
convenient, it's fact. Um, inconvenient
rigged. Um,
>> I just threw this calling by my name,
though, just FYI.
>> We do. It's a C. Uh, there like like
right there. Um, Dub, sorry, you went to
say something to Lost and he's back.
>> Oh, no. Yes. So, I posted more.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, I posted more and there
there's more, right?
>> Okay. Is this in Discord?
>> Uh, I it's in the group. Yeah. So, there
there's a lot more. Um, and so the last
one I just posted is uh so I'm trying to
verify this, right? I don't want to say
actually I just want to say I'm not sure
if it's true, right? But, um, so I'll
clear that up after I like have to look
into it. So, but I think that's enough
evidence that yeah, he has been involved
in the doxing. Uh Dan's been involved in
boxing. Uh this Niko Sam guy seems like
uh like legitimate, right? What he said
in that guy said in the email,
>> I think I don't know if I've said this,
but um Nico Sam came to me with the
exact things he put on uh like I it's
like basically public information.
NicoSam went on KF and said that Dan
came to him with the Twitter account
that docks President Sunday and that he
he basically believes that Dan was
involved in doxing President Sunday.
Nikosam came with that to me. I said I'm
not going to publish it because I don't
want to publish this. Right? I'm not I'm
not a publisher. Don't come to me to
publish stuff. Okay? You make a public
statement, I'll cover it. But if you
don't want to make a public statement,
then I like I don't know what to do,
right? And I I don't think he wanted to
do it that way. So I I passed, but I he
brought this to me I want to say in like
like January, February of this year. Um
so I' I've kind of known about that, but
realistically like there's not a lot of
proof there. It's just him being in
those servers and then saying, "Yes,
like uh like I was given this this
Twitter account by Dan or I was told to
look at this Twitter account by Dan."
And there's something about like the
language is the same as the language
Destiny uses when he goes to docs when
he goes to doc Sunday in his DG chat,
which he did by the way. Um yeah,
there's some other stuff there. So, I
have like some like side proof that the
Nikico Sam like I I know that that's
Niko Sam who thinks that, right? where
I'm 99% sure that it's Nikico Sam who
who was saying that. Um he gave me like
a whole document but I I like I said
just publishing it seemed weird when it
did when it was light on evidence. It
was just his like innuendo, but this
came out of like the server where
>> on the like the 22nd I think or like it
was like three or four three or five
three or four days before Destiny said
on stream that they were trying to find
this girl, right?
>> Yeah, I can see all that.
>> Yeah, all that seems to match up to me,
right? So this and this is why I think
yeah, he's been involved with this kind
of stuff and I can't find anything.
>> Well, okay. Sorry, I keep doing my hand
thing. Um, yeah, I understand that at
this juncture like the burden is on me.
Oh, just real quick as well, I should
rehighlight that Niku Sam gave all this
stuff up, that he wants to be left
alone, that he is not involved in any of
this stuff. Just he was involved. Uh he
saw the error of his ways. He's no
longer involved. Okay, leave Niku Sam
alone. Leave Nico alone to show that
this is a countdock and not just a first
strike, if you will. So, I do understand
that and I apologize. I don't use
Discord on my computer very often and
it's updating and I'm on my phone on the
uh this stupid app streamard thing and
so every time I like downsize the window
it it kicks me out. So just bear with me
and I'll uh I'll be on tomorrow too if
you want to chat it up.
>> Sure. Yeah, of course.
>> Yeah. I don't know I don't know if if if
that like meets your standard, right? Um
but this is just the first thing that
like I could find um which is um from
the Triple 9 Society, right? So they
require either Stanford Renee or the um
Wesler. Yeah, there's there's like so
much better content going on. I'm just
so I have to go.
>> Uh, thank you uh DBY. Um, thank you
Alexander $5 saying I'll never spend
Cory's name.
>> Yo, I just wanted to say I appreciate
the discourse. Still love you, bud.
>> He was just saying he likes you. You're
>> like social progressive like social like
you know like a
>> one of the things does take courage to
come and defend your position. I think
more people should do it as opposed to
just anonymously trash talkinging in the
chat. Uh, and you should look into
>> He didn't defend his positions at all.
His positions are completely
indefensible. He had no evidence for
them. He is totally brainwashed, right?
Like this is just embarrassing. Don't
say, "Oh, you did a good job coming on
when he's a totally brainwashed."
That's embarrassing for you, too. Oh,
well, I'm glad you came on to like
embarrass yourself here in front of
everybody and show up and make strong
assertions and have absolutely no proof
for them whatsoever. It's It's so goofy,
dude. He Yes, he absolutely gloated. He
was, "Oh, I'm going to post evidence
before Dubie." And then he types a whole
bunch. He goes AFK for like 15 minutes
and comes back and goes, "Guys, this is
really complicated. I can't post. I
don't know. I don't know, man. This is
really complicated." And you could see
even his argument on on some of the Rose
stuff is like, "Would Destiny Destiny's
a smart guy. Would he really do that?"
Yes. Yes. He's a Yes. He's a on this
topic. Would Destiny really just lie?
Would Destiny really just like make a
horrible decision? Would he really just
like out himself for retaining Cam?
Would he really do that? Yes. Yes, he
would. do the psychological profile of
online trolls. Not so great.
>> Oh, Cory, how do you how do you you've
been on this panel for years and you're
always so pleasant. I don't understand
how you maintained this uh decorum for
>> I also score high on sociopathy. So,
>> Palestine Prime, thanks for having me,
boys. It's
>> okay. All right. Well, that was a panel.
That was a panel that existed. That was
a thing. Let's uh let's check out Let's
see here. Uh the person who updates
Destiny's sheet is uh maybe they're
turning anti. The person who usually
gives the time stamps for Destiny's
stream didn't do that today for some
reason. So now I have to go scan this on
my own, which is [__] up. All right,
let me go see where we get to Ethan
stuff here. Son scanning for an Ethan
time stamp. I could just try to go to O,
but I don't really want to just go do O.
There's some Ethan right here. Okay, on
to the Ethan stuff, guys. Let's see what
happens.
>> Destiny update video.
>> Uhoh.
>> Which does anyone care? Like, bro, you
>> Hey, Lawson did literally exactly what I
told you the other DJs do when you ask
for evidence. I beg them for something,
anything, and promise to change my tune
if it's concrete enough. And they just
say he's formed a hate community. That's
literally it. Yeah, I know. But, but the
sad thing is is like I This is how you
know that it's like cultish, right? Is
when they don't feel embarrassed about
that. When they will go back to make
that argument again. They'll say they
could prove it and then they embarrass
themselves again. They'll just embarrass
themselves again and embarrass
themselves again. That's like the
cultlike thing where that I've noticed.
And it's just like I can't really like
handle it anymore. It was It was like
funny for a little bit to bring them on
and humiliate them and make them like
look really stupid and and like I I have
a hard time doing it, you know, more
than once now. There was a time period
where I could do it like endlessly and
now it's just like, okay, this is like
this is like what they actually want.
They're like getting off to it. This is
what they want.
>> Does anyone care? Oh, they're Oh,
they're so happy. Oh my god. All the
guys in the chairs finally have somebody
that they can laugh with Ethan about
again because they've been too much of a
spineless coward to say anything about
their actual come source Hassan for the
past year while Ethan's been [__] source.
He's doing it again. He's talking about
He's talking about it again. Take a
everybody take a there's there's a come
reference. Godamn going on stream. Oh,
how cute. I'm so happy that they all
bond over
>> you. You click anywhere on this VOD and
you're like 30 seconds away from a come
reference.
>> I will be your shared enemy that you
hate. That's fine. I hope that um raid
DJers don't hack their accounts again
like uh what was it? That's that
Stariller, the AB guy when he was caught
posting in a snark um in the Snark
subreddit and then he was like I think
it was actually
>> dude actually. What the [__] I've never
even Google who [__] this guy was. What?
I still don't even know how the crow on
the show. I only know this guy's Dan
because I have a Dan and they're both
called I don't even know who these
people are. I Who is this guy? Who's
this guy? I've only watched like hours
and hours and hours of their content.
I've totally know who he is. I totally
talked about how he saves Ethan. I've
totally made actual statements about him
as a person before. But now, because I'm
mad at them, I'm going to pretend I
don't know this guy. Cool. Very cool.
How that's like that has to be peak
narcissism, right? Where the biggest
insult you can do to somebody is saying
you don't know who they are. That's got
to be what peak narcissism is. I don't
even know who this guy is. Who even is
this guy? Who even are these people?
It's like that's the best thing you
could give to them is the the
recognition that you know them. Dan
>> like arguing the semantics of like
actually it's called a heopile. It means
I just want to [__] teenagers, not not
children.
>> Who's even arguing any of this? You
called me a and now you're saying that
if you 19year-old it's the same thing.
There's a
>> I just think it's funny to have the
matching title to go with the entire
look, right? Personally, like now I have
plausible deniability to call him a
because he minor or sorry, tried to [__]
minor, right? So I have the plausible
deniability to say it now, you know, by
internet rules. But if you push me, I'll
say dictionary wise, no, it's primary
attraction to to previous kids, and I
don't believe Destiny has that, right?
But now I can match like the the facial
look, the overall look that he has to
the title. And that's just exciting.
Okay. It's like match. It's like, dude,
it's like um Oh, it's like playing what
what's the memory game. You know the
memory game where you pick the pairs,
right? It's like finding the first pair
there. You've like done a couple
concentration. Is that what it's called?
It's like I see the picture and I get
the word turned over and I'm like,
"Yes." Oh, it just feels good to connect
them finally.
Being a kids. Okay. Something that your
country Israel is tough
>> notoriously known for giving cover for
pro Palestine. I need an Arabic a shahid
or raid or whatever it's called song
button on my soundboard. Okay.
>> Like is that really the conversation
we're going to be having here with
Destiny?
>> Who is having the comment? Just don't
accuse me of that you have no idea
about. That's how hard is that? How
>> Destiny, did you or did you not retain
CSAM? Destiny, did you or did you not
retain CSAM? This is another thing that
Ethan does. Unfortunately, when Ethan
knows that Destiny's going to react, he
should just say, "Destiny, the question
you won't answer is, did you or did you
not retain CSAM?" Destiny, did you or
did you not? If that girl is 17, did you
or did you not retain CSAM? Hard is
that?
>> Um, like I like unfortunately that's
really the question that you would want
to ask, right? Did you retain job? Did
you retain job? Did you retain job
without alerting the authorities? Did
your Did your lawyers I want I want
actually this on the record, too. Did
your lawyers advise you to retain child
because that child would be
consequential in your civil case? Didn't
you didn't you say that? Because that's
the counter-argument to that, by the
way, that oh, he needs it for a civil
case. No, he doesn't. It literally can't
be evidence in a civil case. It can't be
evidence. The civil case is not a child
thing. The CSAM itself cannot be
evidence in that case. He's always like,
why do we even have to talk about it?
Why don't even like, bro, you're the one
who's reading down my Kiwi Farms thread
on your show. Oh, what the
>> actually I didn't have 60 gigs of of
child only only one picture. I actually
only had one video of child.
>> We're going to get a no response to that
one.
>> You know this.
>> Save it for the video.
>> I don't respond to that one or
>> notice how he lets that one go. That
one. Every other one he's really really
really fast to jump in and go stop
making things up Ethan. You're making
things up. And then Ethan says that he's
like what? Like who's forcing you? Who's
the person who is forcing this guy to
make videos about me? There's got to be
like some super.
>> It just didn't answer the question at
all. He just let it go by, right? I have
zero bites of cesam is something he
could have said. He could have said
anything.
>> What? Good guy.
>> Only one picture.
>> I actually only had one video of child.
I'm actually I don't know if you know
this.
>> Save it for the video.
>> I don't feel like making it [__]
dumb.
>> Okay, good. What? Who's for I don't feel
like making it cuz it's so dumb. You the
person who is forcing this guy to make
videos about me. There's got to be like
some super
controller
of all the people behind the scenes and
I just need to get connected to that
guy. Like who's controlling Hassan?
Who's controlling Ethan? Who's
controlling everybody to hate me? It's a
deep state conspiracy.
My uh my ears are burning, guys. My ears
are burning. Oh boy. My ears are burning
right now. He doesn't know. He doesn't
know. He doesn't know.
>> Bring up his Boston bombing vid. Why?
What happened? Did he
>> Dude, imagine being the most unlikable
seam retaining adjacent person on planet
Earth. Okay. And all you can say is
exasperated is sigh. All you can do is
sigh with exasperation. Go. Why do all
these people not like me? Why doesn't
anybody like me? All these people are so
weird that they don't like me. No, it's
like the most natural thing in the
world, actually. You're like an awful
human being. You You flaunt that
proudly.
At least, dude, the reason people kind
of liked you before is cuz you look like
a smart person, too. You're awful, but
at least you're smart. Kind of like
House. Now you look like a like a
malicious evil. Like, you've lost the
last redeeming quality you had. People
are like, "He's so smart that he might
save democracy even though he's an awful
person." No, now you just look like a
[__] idiot, too. You've lost like
you've lost the one thing that redeemed
you in like some people's minds was you,
oh, you're smart and you could help save
democracy. No, that's not happening.
Also, yeah, history alert. Ethan is the
product of a ebopile relationship. Okay,
cuz his dad was 21 and his mom was 16
when they
>> You were 33 and she was 17. You were 33
and she was 17. You were 33 and she was
17. You were 33 and she was 17. It's
much weirder. It's much weirder. It's
much much much weirder. Okay. I dude
>> name it. That's confirmed.
>> The same.
>> I'm happy to go home.
>> I know Willie Mack is making an update.
Did he post? I don't know.
>> Check it out. He's going to lay it all
out.
>> Destiny was my roommate. I get him late
all the time.
>> That Z trick is still working with him.
Okay.
>> Exactly.
>> I'm just looking forward to now. Like
the thing we look forward to now, I
assume, is um the people in these group
chats or people close to Destiny turning
on him as well, right? Like Willie Mack
was the first one that realized, oh
[__] we got to get out. But who's the
next one? Who's the next one? He shared
some videos with what he was looking for
all where he's looking for Rose or
whatever the [__] been going on, right?
Who's the next one to turn? He's he's
doing all these jokes. He's doing a lot
of memeing, but in the back of his head,
he's got to be thinking like, who's the
next one, right? Who's left? Well, I'm
just saying that like I haven't heard
Ardite speak. I haven't really heard Dan
make a statement like are one of these
people going to come out and go you know
what we actually have to we actually
have to abandon ship we got to show we
got to show that Darius has left. Ooh
I've heard I've heard Darius had a bunch
of stuff right? I've heard Darius had a
whole bunch of stuff. What about Lerbox?
Lerbox is not on Destiny's side like it
not in a tangible like I understand that
Lonerbox is just like a show me the
evidence kind of guy. All right like I
need to see all the evidence or
something.
There's probably more than that. I I
don't want to talk about her box.
Computer isn't working. I'm sure she'll
come out against him soon. I We'll see.
We'll see.
>> Um actually, this text message was with
somebody else. I've only spoke
inappropriately with other teenagers
three or four times. Not this one in
particular.
>> That person was in there twy
or
he's freaking out cuz Ethan showed those
other texts. Did Ethan not go through
and just show like what was real and
what wasn't? Did he not like follow up
today or because yeah, showing those
texts and saying they were from Rose is
probably pretty bad, but why not just go
through the actual text from Rose if
you're going to do that?
>> Incredibly weird and creepy. If he
thought Just think about how weird and
creepy it is if he thought that these
were child texts back and forth. Why the
is he reading it off on
um if that was actually me? Why are you
like mad about it and and reading them
off? Why why would you read Why would
you read those off? Um that's like
really bad. That's really bad of you.
Why not? The argument would be that it's
a it's a you know semi not semi-even.
It's like act involving a minor and so
even with those you should refrain. I've
kind of like let it go when it's um on
other people's stuff or when it's like
you know evidence for a point. I've not
gone through and read it all. I I don't
know if I could like I don't know if I
could really justify going through and
reading them all. Right. Text can't be
seam. I'm aware text can't be seam. It's
still like um it's still like it's
bordering on something that's weird.
Right. That counts as cam. I don't think
it counts as seam. Well, sorry. I don't
think it counts as like child of the
law. I don't think like those texts
would be um I don't think there's an
argument that those texts would would
count the same way as like actual child.
Reading Vos DMs recently got some
people's YT hit. Yeah, it would.
Unironically, next Jer needs to provide
an outline to Ethan for him to make a
video. It's too much lore. Uh, Ethan can
pay researchers. Ethan has more than
enough money. If he could pay to sue
Caseyron, he can pay researchers to make
his anti-destiny video. Okay? He could
not be a lazy loser. Okay? Or if he's
going to be a lazy loser, pay some
people. You're rich as stream. Are you
crazy? Like, if you legitimately think
that these are inappropriate
conversation between an adult and a
minor, why are you gooning to the
material on your stream? That's so
weird. What the There's something
particularly disconcerting about a
person who did have a relationship um
like a relationship with a minor going
drawing attention to this by reading off
what I said is actually really gross on
your part. Okay. Like referencing the
fact that Destiny and this minor were
discussing a a shared going twinsies on
butt plugs like that is apparently
offensive to Destiny in a way that
retaining the CSAM was not right. in a
way in a way that leaking all of his
private relationship texts with Lauren
Southern to this 19-year-old he'd only
known for like 3 months was not sorry
purported 19-year-old purported
18-year-old whatever age he thought she
was right he knew she was like either
freshly 18 or like somewhere between you
know 17 and 19 okay and he shared all of
his romantic romantic messages with
somebody who's apparently the love of
his life with that teenager who he'd
only known for like 3 months I don't
know that to me is like another one of
those things I realize assuming assuming
he thinks she's an adult or like 18,
right? That might be one of the more
disgusting things in there to be honest
with you. Like you think that's your
soulmate and you're going to you're
going to share all of your extremely
personal private texts for your like
trying to save the relationship with a
minor sex worker that you've known well
sorry with a sex worker that you've
known for 3 months. Shouldn't include
the minor part. He might not have known
it. That's that's wild to me. That's
crazy. Bro, you're you're a creep.
You're a deviant creep with a clear
persistent pattern of trying to flirt
with with fantasize a pattern. All of my
major dramas are with older women even.
How old was Lav or was Lav 15? I don't
know. Maybe everybody
pattern of being an abusive piece of
[__] Um I don't think he's a pattern of
what is it? Like a pattern of targeting
children? Yeah, I don't think so.
Really, if anything, we could say he's a
pattern of ignoring children, right?
like a pattern of targeting children.
No, it's like the opposite pattern of
being a total piece of [__] also. Yes.
Lies by their birthday. Annavoir was my
age, right? Like minus 2 years. Was she
lying about her age? What are all of
these? What the dude? This whole cadence
is like so unbelievable to me now. Uh I
occasionally see names that I'm just
like this Wicked Demier guy who's
actually really smart. It's like really
depressing that he is uh like a full-on
cult member. That's sad.
>> It's about minors.
Just admit that that you're that's and
people defending Destiny. Just admit
that that you're cool with that.
>> You can keep watching Destiny. You can
keep being a fan. But we don't need to
argue the semantics, you know, of it.
Just just admit that he's a creep and
that he wants to [__] teenagers.
>> If you want to call me a creep, okay,
then fine. I don't give a call a creep.
I don't give a Why would I care? Okay,
you can't even make it through four.
>> Um,
child connoisseur is probably what I go
with. I think child connoisseur is like
a punchy gets the point across.
Factually correct. Okay. Child
afficionado. Something along these
lines. Something like this would be
better. Don't call him a creep cuz that
kind of minimizes, right? He's like a
child dragon. He's like sits on a horde
of child. I'm not totally sure. We could
find it. We we'll find it. There's a
there's there's a word for it. Words
without I'm sorry. No, I'm not sorry for
this guy. If you don't call me creep,
that's fine. But there's a huge
difference between creep versus
predator. Like you have to understand
there's a big difference between these
two things. All right.
>> Not like weird not like weird like
almost like like they've gone through
puberty teenagers.
>> I I would love if somebody asked Destiny
why he thought he would be done if she
was a minor cuz it seems like
something's changed there. Why did he in
his own opinion think that he would be
done if she was a minor? That he'd be
cooked. Is it almost like he understands
exactly why that line's there and why
that line is so bad when creators cross
it?
>> 161 17. He just wants to [__] 16 17 year
olds. It's not pett.
>> What the [__] What?
>> Um, technically it's only
>> Wait, where are all of these other girls
and people coming from? 15year-old, 16
year olds? What What are we talking
about? Does he have like a fanfiction?
>> I just wonder when he started texting
Molina. How old was Molina when you guys
started texting? Like this does happen.
Um, I don't think he has like a primary
sexual attraction to little girls or
something, but I I mean some kind of
like a violating social convention
maybe. In any case, uh yeah, this this
we're just starting to see that like
this guy was a total piece of [__]
before this. Uh it is it is funny and
it's it's funny that what might get him
his comeuppance is his hoarding of the
Cam, like the actual child. But it does
come down to ultimately it's why Ryan
Beard's first video is the best takedown
of Destiny, right? because it shows the
pattern of behavior, how he's just a
totally like he's totally psychotic to
anybody who threatens like his
community's view of him. If anybody is
like basically promoting a message that
he is a bad person, his community is at
all bought into it, that person has to
be destroyed mercilessly. That's like
kind of the more perpetual pattern over
time that he's writing in his mind of
me.
>> Pedophilia, if they haven't hit puberty,
>> I would say yes. Hold on. That jiggle
girl was 16. I don't know how old she
was cuz she says she's 16. I don't
totally know. But um what I would say is
I don't think he is at all morally
opposed to girl who is like in that age
range if he could get away with it.
Right. Seems like that's pretty clear
like he's made that clear over time. So
whatever that is wouldn't say it's a
primary attraction but whatever the that
is right.
>> I actually want to [__] women or I
actually want to [__] little girls who
have hit puberty but are still under the
age of consent. That's my preference.
>> I would have more respect for the
defenders if they were just like yeah
I'm cool with it.
>> Okay. Someone said Ethan you shouldn't
exaggerate the destiny of claims. Okay.
Well, yeah, of course, but that's
because you support 9-year-olds getting,
right? Isn't he Muslim or whatever? So,
your opinion is obviously not very
relevant here. Thank you.
>> You shouldn't exaggerate the destiny of
claims. Okay, so I'm making this video.
>> Old and horrifying video of H3H. I don't
want to do this. Do I care?
>> Hey guys, here. Watch your hands cuz you
you're going to get cut up on this one
here, guys. You can scar me. This
>> I'm going to go back to A and just see
if I've got any other clips here.
Watching this guy kind of makes me ill.
He said that once. Wait, he said what
once?
Oh, that he just doesn't care. I mean,
he said it more than once that he just
doesn't care or professed it at least
once.
So, more than once. Let me see here. Let
me see if there's anything else in this
back and forth. Ethan not has no idea
about takes at Israel and Ethan's
parents. There was a lowb blow at AB. I
think that's just it. See what we got
for comments here. All these people to
hate me. Yes, this was the funny part.
Okay. Who's controlling all these people
to hate me? I only needed one reason to
Destiny. Just one. But ever since you
celebrated the death of Cory Comparator,
I've been given so many more reasons to
utterly despise you. Yeah, he really
needs to shut up if he wants to come out
of his the investigations lawsuits
without going to jail. Isosu is a
19-year-old child. She was not 19. I
think we all have a pretty good idea of
what it's about. The docs, the [__]
himself just to hit just to get hit with
the hard truth. He's a kitty freak.
Sucks to suck. O replies, "Man, I
thought there was going to be something
sick here, but this is not the evil
Stark behavior that Ethan is falling
for." What? Okay. All right. Um, are we
going to I think we close off with the
Aiden stuff tonight. Is that where we're
going? End of the stream. We're going to
close up with the Aiden stuff. What else
do we got here? Just making sure I don't
Didn't forget anything. Am I pulling up
that Aiden stream? I've got the AB and
Preach video. Is there anybody who's not
who's been waiting? Okay. Hasn't posted
the AB and Preach video. Oh, this is the
other thing. Kathy, so nice of you to
join us, Kathy. Apparently, so I didn't
go watch the whole H3 episode. There's
this part as well. The clip that O
doesn't want us to see. Hold on. Destiny
CPS. Oh.
>> Oh, my good friend.
>> Lots of on Ian for being a total dope
idiot weirdo. Uh, lots of Destiny
followup, which we're in a VOD. That
would that means a VOD on demand will be
after this episode ends to be brought to
you postp.
>> Oh, wait. They're going to do another
one. Wait, is that out yet? That might
>> for enjoying the VODs. Everybody's, you
know, people are turning around on the
VODs. They are saying, "We love VODs.
They're doing wonderful things with the
VODs.
>> The VODs are, you know, the best VODs."
Lots of
>> I hope CPS takes his kids. I'll say it.
I do. And I hope they cry about it. And
then CPS come for my kid. And then CPS
can take Dan's kids. You know what? All
of our children at the end of the day
will just be fostered by Child
Protective Services. Okay? And that'll
just be And then we can all relieve
ourselves. It's He's just going to be a
rehash of all the every other video
made. God, it's so crazy how this
>> I don't particularly care about the uh
the CPS comment. It is ironic coming
from him given his situation. It's
ironic. Um dude, this guy is just like
playing all sides of everything right
now, right? He just doesn't actually
believe in anything. And then they can
take dance kids, too. I'm going to just
keep making it absurd now. Now that I
said I'm just going to keep making it
absurd, more and more absurd. And oh,
and also, is this going to be the same
as every other video? Probably not. I
don't think I don't think most of the
videos out about Destiny right now are
talking about his uh his doxing of the
girl to his Kiwi Farms thread like his
him providing PII to find her and
basically himself in the foot here.
Okay. I don't think there's I haven't
seen a punchy video about it yet.
There's not a single video that is
punchy and shows that he provided the
information that led to people realizing
he'd been storing Cessam on his
computer. I mean, Wait, did you see the
low blow that Destiny took at AB?
Oh, the what the is this different? So,
I saw the the a clip for a second, but
is this different than the
what was it that you're a Muslim
puberty?
>> I actually want to
have hit puberty but are still under the
age of 9year-olds.
>> That's my
>> I would have more respect for the
defenders if they were just like, "Yeah,
I'm cool with it."
>> Okay. Someone said, "Ethan, you
shouldn't exaggerate the destiny of
claims." Okay.
>> Well, yeah, of course, but that's
because you support 9year-olds getting
right. Isn't he Muslim or whatever? So,
your opinion is obviously not very
relevant here. Thank you.
>> You shouldn't exaggerate the destiny of
claims. Okay. You guys want me?
>> Okay, this is the Tree of Logic clip we
had on stream. So, box, I I ser I swear
to God if I click on this and it doesn't
work, I am uh I I'm telling you right
now, I will swear off kick clips for
like until it's fixed. If this breaks,
I'm going to lose it.
>> Any [__] goddamn pooky who goes after
little girls who
>> Oh, we watched this on stream already,
but we'll watch it again.
>> [__] age is a goddamn piece of [__]
Clip that. Get mad at that.
>> Oh, Wes. Yeah, I'm I'm looking forward
to watching the Streamhouse. Is Wes
doing it or is it just all in Sam's
stream? Where where is it getting done?
Where can I find the clips cuz I saw
that as well? Okay. Anyway, we we aren't
done by Child Protective Services. Okay.
And that'll just be and then we can all
relieve ourselves. He's just going to be
a rehash of all the every other video
made. God, it's so crazy how this
um as he's spamming on Instagram and
coughing and dying of whatever diseases
he has.
>> Destiny was totally psyched when Ethan
would do the same thing to Hassan, by
the way. Destiny loved it. Destiny
absolutely loved it.
>> Is is telling me like, "Oh, Destiny, I
used to like you so much and you need
help and blah blah blah." It's like the
the exact the exact Assad was doing to
him.
Good memes. Oh, wow. Oh boy. All of
these guys are like pointing fingers.
It's just Spider-Man pointing at
Spider-Man pointing at Spider-Man
pointing at a Okay. Like all these
people are terrible. They do lie about
each other because they've gotten past
the point where they care to validate
any story about one another, right? Just
one of them retained several cam videos,
right? Multiple CSAM videos.
Unfortunately, that puts him lower than
the rest of the like totally amoral to
our massive streamers. Okay. Unlucky.
Unlucky. Unlucky. I dislike Destiny, but
what happened? Innocent till proven
guilty. Why are we calling him a before
solid evidence? I don't know. It's just
weird to me. Um, trip to pound town. He
literally said he retained the videos of
Rose. We know that the videos of Rose
were when she was 17 or younger because
time works linearly.
So, he has retained a bunch of CSAM for
months without alerting the authorities.
We're calling him a because he's holding
child. Is that technically the
definition of No, but it is enough for
most people. If you hold, you know,
gigabytes and gigabytes of child, people
will call you a
breaks, buddy. Do you need any proof of
that? Cuz I'm perfectly happy to walk
through it with you. Or is that just
some random concern trolling and we're
going to run away now? Cuz that's
basically the argument you have to make
that I don't believe this guy is a We
have not seen the evidence though. It's
all hearsay. No, Destiny's direct
testimony is this. This is Destiny's
direct testimony. Destiny has said this
directly. Destiny received multiple
videos. He has retained all files
received from Rose. What do you think
that means? Destiny has taken videos
received from Rose and sent stills from
those videos to a group chat trying to
find Rose. How did he do that without
retaining CSAM? This is proven. This is
not an allegation. This there is full-on
evidence to show this. There's Destiny's
own testimony, his own recollection, his
own statement of fact being the
strongest piece of evidence. Oh my god.
What's the evidence that she's 17? I'll
I'll give you the tweet of a man with at
least 30 IQ points on you, Draciel. Hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. Tom Foolery P. Let
me go find the Tom Fooly thing. I'll put
that in the I'll put that in the chat
for you. Tom harvesting W's now. Okay.
Tom's just harvesting W's. That's crazy.
at Draciel right there, buddy. Right
there. Tom explains it. You just go read
Tom's post. Uh yeah, go check it out.
Did the trip to pound town guy just not
want to? Desty said she was 17. Oh, we
have all of the evidence in the world.
She was 17, right? Well, let's read it.
Let's read it just so you guys can
actually read it with us just one more
time because it is it is important.
Okay. I don't know how many people have
done this, but I did verify that Rose
was under 18 in 2022. I keep saying or I
keep seeing people say it's unverified.
So, in case you didn't know, I figured
I'd explain it here. There's a photo of
her in DG merch from a Discord server.
Uh, it's not just from a Discord server.
Destiny posted it in DGG chat saying it
was Rose and doxing Rose's college, the
girl's college, right? And her face to
Kiwi Farms while taunting Kiwi Farms and
saying you can't find her, right? So,
okay. So, that's the first piece of
evidence is Desty says this is Rose.
Desty gave a picture of her face and her
college. Okay, so this is the same girl
in the that photo. The same girl in that
photo is the same person in the news
interview, the news interview at the
beginning of the Willy video. The name
on the news interview is the same as the
name on the speeding ticket as is the
city. So the city is the same. The name
is the same. The speeding ticket has her
birthday, her birth month. That makes
her 17 at the time, turning 18 on
October. Most state websites don't put
two-digit years, but I've confirmed that
this one does by looking up more names
and found 87,71, 92, etc. So, showing
that they have to be uh what do you call
it? Like years instead of months or
dates. Okay. I've searched her name in
other places to see the same name, face,
and birth date all match other websites.
Right. Destiny also said in DG chat in
May what college Rose went to. That the
same individual went to that same
school. So, if you don't trust people
who have claimed to verify it so far,
add me to the list. Not making any
claims about anyone knowing or when they
knew only that she was 17 until October
of 2022. I told my audience days ago
that it was confirmed, but I figured I'd
put it here, too. Uh, Dracul, yes, the
site literally has a tick mark for
juveniles. She is not a juvenile any
longer, so her profile no longer shows
her as juveniles. U, there's also public
record of both her and her mother being
served as a part of a hit and run that
happened, right? Both her and her mom
were served. That only apparently
happens if she's a juvenile. But
regardless, it shows that um that this
is the same person and that the birth
date is correct. Like you're literally
arguing with government systems that are
accurate for everybody. Yes, it was a it
was a traffic citation. Trip to pound.
Destiny himself has said he is in
possession of it. Destiny himself has
produced artifacts of it and said that
they are artifacts of the videos. Trip
to pound. Do you understand that Destiny
himself says, "Yes, I do have this video
of Rose having said, "Yes, here is a
screen of this video showing the title
of the video with Rose having said that
is something Destiny has said. Do you
understand?" I I shouldn't be shocked
because we've watched Destiny admit
things before over Discord messages,
right? I violated her privacy in the
most egregious way possible and many
people will argue that that was not a
confession of guilt, right? Many sorry,
totally brain will argue that that's not
a confession of guilt. So that live that
ticket is a live document that updates
with her age. No. When you look up her
profile on the website, that is a live
profile that updates with her age as in
when she's no longer a juvenile.
Apparently doesn't take juvenile
anymore. So she is no longer a juvenile,
right? She was a juvenile in 2022. So
the ticket is a part of her profile. The
profile updates over time. The ticket
would be an immutable artifact. Are you
still confused? Um there's also So
there's a new piece of evidence that
came out recently. Somebody sent it to
me. I'll read this off. Give me a
second. Give me a second. Give me a
second. So, I don't know if you've
heard. It's a new bit of evidence. Car
accident at 16 in 2021. And there is a
record of this. Oh, there's a record of
this. And not only that, but she was
sued for it. She was sued for it. And
there's a Facebook post of the person
who was hit by the car, and they say, "A
16 year old girl hit me today." Lines up
totally with the time and the age.
There's a Facebook post of the person
who got hit saying they're in the
hospital and I got [__] up by I got
hit by a 16-year-old girl today. So, she
tried to So, this is actually the same
ticket. So, she actually got sued for
this. She was trying to run a red light.
>> She got hit or sorry, she hit this
person
>> just tipped uh
>> $3.
>> How mad will the haters be when this
drama blows over and people still prefer
even CP can do it? A real Mantis tweet
on X.
She was 16 in 2021 when she got into the
accident. There is a record of the civil
litigation for the same person who makes
the Facebook post with the girl who is
named because as if it's a part of her
juvenile record. Why is it released now?
I Who are you? Is this guy talking to
somebody else? It's not a part of a It's
not not criminal. They're civil. They're
civil records, right? There's not a
criminal action taking place. She didn't
get arrested or if she did get arrested,
that's not public record. That's not
what we're looking at. I I really even
more than um even more than just talking
about like the actual facts of the
matter. Dracula, don't you feel like
weird when everybody here can can look
at this evidence? They can identify it.
Um lots of a ton of neutral people can
look at this evidence, identify it. Tom
Foolery, who is a massive Destiny fan,
who is totally monetarily incentivized
to continue supporting Destiny, can look
at this evidence and go, "Yeah, it's
obvious that this person was 17." Does
that not concern you that you are
sitting here arguing against like
bulletproof evidence like this? I would
just I I would personally feel a little
concerned that I'm I'm sitting there
like not knowing stuff right from a
place of ignorance arguing that
everybody else is wrong. That would feel
concerning to me. I understand it
doesn't disturb you, but have you
thought about why that might be? Yeah,
that's another fantastic point. Albert,
yes, Destiny doesn't seem to deny that
she's likely 17. Okay, we took that
little bit of time. I don't believe the
Ethan video is out yet, guys. I would
love to watch that Ethan video if it
were out, but it's not out yet. Probably
have to be content for tomorrow. Let's
go to the Aiden Underground stream for a
quick second. All right,
>> controversy.
>> So, if you guys don't remember
yesterday, okay, Aiden had bit of
controversy yesterday.
He went live. Purple Perry looked at his
DMs. Purple Perry Gaming went and looked
through his DMs while Aiden walked away
from his computer. Leaked that Nicholas
Yorio was apparently seething about
Queen in Aiden's DMs. Kind of goofy. Is
this Dracula guy still asking questions?